a brand new month is approaching and
that means it's the perfect time
to let go you can play the 30-day
minimalism game and also
download our free printable 30-day
minimalism game calendar
over at theminimalists.com game
enjoy minimalists
diana says i struggle with wanting to
learn about
high quality items i can buy in order to
replace the cheaper things
i own the notion of additional
consumption in order to ultimately own
and consume
less so uh diana is basically having a
problem with
wanting to replace her low quality items
with higher quality items
yeah and it's interesting because during
the pandemic
i see people getting bored and so then
they start to make
reasons or excuses to shop online and
maybe even the shop in person
uh because you know retail stores are
starting to open back up
although some of them will never open
back up i don't know i struggle with
this too but
as one of the minimalists i'm perfect so
i don't struggle with it anymore
no man you know the thing that stands
out the most to me is my
stinking and even talking about it kind
of makes me feel like i just need to do
it but i'm not gonna do it
uh my scale and my kettle so for my
coffee scale
and the kettle i used to heat the water
i bought them both from blue bottle
they work great they work great
now what's funny is i've had to replace
these things at least once
blue bottle i went back to blue bottle
and got these same exact things
okay they let they both only lasted
about a year and a half
so um i went back to blue bottle
re-bought those things that was like
three years ago so
something either i was doing or the
quality like something has changed where
these are lasting longer than they
did the first time but within those
three years boop blue bottle
now has this like gorgeous kettle
i mean it's freaking art man it's
amazing it does the same exact thing
that my kettle does now
um it's just it's unbelievably beautiful
though and
the same thing with the scale they have
a coffee scale that like matches
the kettle and it is it's art again the
scale is art the kettle is art
and i could even justify and say you
know what
i'm going to enjoy these things more
which might be true
but i also understand that
it's it's such a ephemeral joy that i'll
get from those things
that i'm willing to put it off until i
absolutely need to replace it
yeah so you know how does this translate
for
diana diana the more you go
with out the more you're going to see
whether or not you need it
and like with this kettle and with this
scale like the more and more i go
without it the more and more i'm like
yeah ryan like you really don't you
really don't need that
beautiful scale and that beautiful
kettle because aesthetics are important
to me now
if i was ocd like someone i know
actually
dude you are someone i know
and you have the same exact scale and
kettle i do right i do
oh dude so maybe you could talk about
that because aesthetics are important to
you they are
so how come you haven't went out and got
this you know what scale and kettle i'm
talking about right
absolutely yeah yeah there's one word
that i wrote it down in fact that you
were talking
uh the word is enough and and
you're right in fact if i had a really
chintzy ugly looking one
yeah okay that's different then i would
probably replace it now
now diana's question and i think that's
where she is she's in this place where
these certain things work uh for her
functionally but they are
they don't work for her aesthetically
they're not beautiful now i do think
beauty is
important in fact uh one of my favorite
lines from
our new film which has been cut uh from
the film
um our favorite cut line from the film
it really is it's actually my favorite
line from any of the interviews when uh
erwin mcmanus was talking about how
beauty is essential
yeah and i i totally agree with that i
think beauty is essential you know it's
the reason people go out into nature
and in the middle of the forest it's
it's it's it's it's just pure beauty
yeah
and it's astonishing right we use these
words that
that that describe some higher being or
or other out of this world experience
otherworldly experience and
and so um i do think beauty is important
however
i do agree with nicodemus here because
it's
quixotic to think that in order to fix
my stuff
problem i'll just buy the right stuff
yeah
that really does sound like a scene out
of don quixote right like like well i'll
just
because you may want to deprive yourself
temporarily
that's the reason ryan did his packing
party for 21 days
is it wasn't about getting rid of
everything and depriving himself in
perpetuity it was about
let me deprive myself temporarily
because i don't even know what's adding
value
anymore and what isn't adding value and
i think what you'll learn
is you'll get by just fine without it
and in fact the bones are often the
beauty the beauty of my kitchen
has little to do with the kettle that i
have and
that the coffee bean grinder and the
blender and everything else but
is that my counters are clutter free
that oh and so so you don't necessarily
see those things
right yeah so yeah if you're not seeing
them then
you don't need to you don't need to
replace them if you're not seeing them
on a regular basis
interesting yeah and last thing i'll say
is i i came across this recently as well
i
uh you know i have six jackets currently
and i was like you know i should just
get one new jacket for this season
and i'll replace all of these six
jackets with that one
that was literally in my mind yeah one
and six out yeah right
and um and then i i thought to myself
well
in fact i i employed several different
rules here that was the first rule the
ten
the one in 10 out rule i was like do i
have 10 things i want to get rid of to
get one jacket
not really i've got six i guess i could
get rid of but
i actually enjoy wearing at least five
of these let me get rid of this one
okay now it's down to five jackets
actually was opposite it was seven now
it's six
anyway uh um but
i i realized like oh
there are other rules here that
certainly work so we have the wait for
it rule
i've been doing this so much more even
with so the wait for it rule is
if it costs more than 30 dollars i wait
at least 30 hours so like
any purchase that's even a medium
purchase i have to wait at least a day
so on amazon it's so easy to what one
click
oh my god it's there immediately in fact
you
just click it and all of a sudden your
doorbell rings and
they knew it yeah they knew you're gonna
buy it yeah it's the algorithm
yeah and and so i i found that
um i was doing that
a little bit too frequently with things
that things i may buy
like even like sponges or whatever i'm
going to purchase
and so now i've just been adding things
to my cart and then
on sundays i evaluate my cart and you
wouldn't believe the number of things i
just delete
delete delete delete it's most of it
that's a great idea
and and so even if it's a five dollar
item
and then today sunday then i'll go ahead
and say all right well here's the
honestly i'm actually going to
keep keeping my cart and purchase the
things i i truly need because i'm no
longer attached to the thing once i put
in my car i'm able to let go of it
and then once i go sort through the car
i don't have any attachment oh yeah you
know what i
thought i needed that but or i thought i
wanted it but
man i don't even want to get another box
this is just a pain in the butt
and so realizing that when you bring
more stuff into your house
diana it might just be a giant pain in
your ass
acquiring these new things yeah and
you're gonna have to take care of them
just like you have to take care of the
things you have now
i think the better solution is yes
replace things that absolutely need to
be replaced
but get rid of the things and try not to
replace them for a while
yeah you'd probably be just fine without
it